Und du bist ein Interesse. Und du bist ein Interesse. Und du bist ein Interesse. Und du bist ein Interesse. Und du bist ein Interesse.
Na ja, ich bin sehr aufgeregt, ich bin hauptsächlich aktiv in der Grünen Jugend, aber auch in der Partei und wollte nur mal so ein bisschen erzählen, wie das aus meiner Sicht läuft und...
Ja, du musst keine Angst haben, wir beißen dir nicht den Kopf ab, aber wir hören dir gerne gespannt zu, wie du das erzählst, also wie genau begegnet es da und was passiert da innerhalb der Partei bei dir?
Genau, also ich hab halt mitbekommen, dass ACTA nicht so eine große Rolle gespielt hat, bevor es so im Februar dann mit dieser großen Demo richtig hochgekocht ist, aber seitdem spielt es auch bei uns im Verband eine ziemlich große Rolle und wir hatten dann in Reaktion auf die ACTA-Debatte einen Beschluss gefasst, als Grüne Jugendfeuer auf Bundesebene zum Urheberrecht, wo wir uns klar positionieren, dass wir sagen, so dieser Weg, den ACTA einschlägt, zu verbieten und das Kopierungshindern zu wollen, ist kein Weg und es führt kein Weg dran vorbei, das Filesharing zu legalisieren und wir gehen noch auf viel weiteres ein, wir gehen darauf ein, dass wir es für notwendig halten, dass mir nicht Apple vorschreibt, Ich bin sehr glücklich, dass ich die freundliche Freiheit, was ich irgendwie auf meinem iPod installieren darf und...
Okay, also da geht es sozusagen um die ganz große Freiheit. Der kleine interessante Punkt, auf den ich gerade aufmerksam geworden bin, ist, du hast gesagt, was hat bei euch erst dann eine Rolle gespielt, als die großen Demonstrationen schon am Start waren. Herr Obach hebt gerade beide Finger. Möchtest du dazu etwas?
Ja, ich hab das bei den Grünen durchaus anders erlebt. Also sowohl Jan Albrecht als auch die Skala Keller aus dem Europäischen Parlament, die ja auch viel noch mit den Grünen im Bund zu tun haben, haben da ständig darauf hingewiesen. Auch die Netzpolitiker der Grünen, also Malte Spitz zum Beispiel oder auch Konstantin von Notz, haben immer wieder darauf hingewiesen, aber auch in der Partei hat ihnen einfach keiner zugehört. Es war sehr spannend gewesen. Also es ist einfach nicht nach unten durchgedrungen. Also ich hab das sehr viel mitbekommen. Auf Twitter haben die sehr viel darüber gesprochen, Vorträge, Blogbeiträge, alles. Aber es ist leider nicht nach unten durchgedrungen. Das ist mein Empfinden von außen jetzt, also nicht involviert bei den Grünen.
Florian, ihr habt dann diesen Entschluss gefasst. Wie ist der dann aufgenommen worden? Also von da, wo du aktiv bist?
Ich wollte gerade noch kurz anmelken zum Herrn Urbach. Absolut. Also klar gibt es bei den Grünen auch Leute, die sich sehr früh da eingemischt haben. Aber genau so diese Durchbringung fehlt. Also es waren halt immer so die paar Netzpolitiker. Und zwar halt nicht so die breite Basis. Und so diesen Beschluss, also ich habe den Eindruck, dass er relativ positiv aufgenommen wird mit Leuten, mit denen ich mich drüber unterhalte, also auch über Parteigrenzen hinweg bei Leuten, die halt so diese Einsicht teilen, dass es halt der falsche Weg ist, das Kopieren zu bekämpfen. Und was halt unsere Intention hauptsächlich war, als wir den Antrag verfasst haben, ich bin einer der Mitautoren unserer Intention, war uns in die Partei Interne-Debatte einzumischen, die gerade läuft und die jetzt dann im Sommer oder Herbst, ich glaube, da gibt es noch keinen finalen Termin, wird es bei den Grünen eine große Konferenz geben in Berlin zum Thema Urheberrecht, wo dann halt das ausbalanciert werden soll, welches ja halt so einerseits gibt es eben die Netzpolitiker, wie Malte, wie JPA, wie Konstantin von Notz und so weiter. Und auf der anderen Seite gibt es halt so diese, ähm, ich will jetzt nichts irgendwie undeklomatisches sagen. Ja, die halt so diese Sache von irgendwas müssen, die können sie doch leben und wir müssen irgendwie das Kopieren verhindern. Und die sollen doch bitte alle bei iTunes oder am besten noch irgendwie so auf CD oder Vinyl ihre Musik kaufen.
Okay, ich möchte jetzt aber zzt. sagen, weil diese Schleife wollten wir in der Sendung eh gerade machen. Es ist ja die eine Sache, dass man sagt, okay, da wird so viel kopiert, lass mal irgendwie das Internet absperren. Die andere Seite ist ja, dass es eigentlich noch viel zu wenig konkrete Vorschläge gibt, wie die Leute, deren Musik kopiert wird, doch zu Geld kommen könnten. Hast du da nicht jetzt zwei Fragen sozusagen aus deiner grünen Perspektive? Findet ihr überhaupt, dass die Künstler irgendwie Geld bekommen sollten? Und wenn ja, habt ihr eine Idee, wie das gehen kann?
Erster Hinweis, ich fühle mich nicht dafür zuständig, mir Geschäftsmodelle auszudenken. Ich mache Politik und ich mache keine Geschäftsmodelle für wen auch immer. Zweiter Hinweis, wir fordern als grüne Jugend schon lange ein bedingungsloses Grundeinkommen, von dem jeder Mensch armutsfest, unabhängig davon, ob er an der Erwerbsarbeit nachgeht oder nicht, leben kann. Aus dieser Perspektive halte ich auch diese Debatte um die sogenannte Kulturflatrate oder Kulturwertmark, die auch bei den Grünen relativ intensiv geführt wird, eigentlich für nicht besonders zielführend.
Du sagst, das Problem klärt sich ganz von selber, wenn einfach die Leute alle Geld kriegen, unabhängig davon, was sie machen.
Ich sage nicht, dass sich das Problem von alleine klärt. Ich sage, es wird natürlich Änderungen im Musikmarkt geben und allgemein, aber ich meine, die gab es schon immer. Und einfach zu sagen, wir wollen den Status Quo aus den 90er Jahren irgendwie behalten und ziehen das mit aller Gewalt durch, das finde ich halt nicht besonders sinnvoll. Also bestimmt wird...
Ich möchte halt, dass Sie sich schon unterbrechen, sagen, ich finde es halt genauso kurzfristig, diese Meinung zu vertreten und dann keinen Gegenvorschlag zu haben.
Gegenvorschlag für was?
Genau. Also den Leuten einfach zu sagen, okay, das gültigerecht ist jetzt zwar so am Start, aber das gilt jetzt halt nicht mehr, also so wie du klarkommst. Das ist halt keine gute Diskussionsgrundlage. Das kann man als Ansicht zwar vertreten, aber ich glaube, so als Diskussionsgrundlage ist es eher nicht so hilfreich.
Nein, ich meine, es wird doch weiterhin auch einen Markt für Musik geben. Und was ich mal klarstellen will, es fordert sich auch quasi niemand, das Urheberrecht komplett abzuschaffen, mal außer einzelnen Leuten, sondern es geht halt so um das nicht-kommerzielle Filesharing. Und natürlich wird es bald den Leuten geben, die Geld ausgeben wollen. Man guckt sich Flatter an, also es gibt Leute, die bei Flatter irgendwie richtig gut abfahren. Also wenn man sich mal anguckt, was Tim Pritloff da irgendwie kriegt, okay, das ist ein einzelnes Basis.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, das ist der berühmte Einzelfall.
Flatter auch bekannt als der Tim-Pritloff-Finanzierungsfund. Aber ich sehe schon, das bedarf auf jeden Fall noch mal genauerer perspektivischer Darstellung. Flöre, an dir erstmal vielen Dank für den Einblick in die Perspektive. Und viel Spaß noch. Und jetzt würde ich nämlich euch fragen, weil da wollten wir gerade hin. Flöre hat zwar gesagt, ja, also diese ganze Sache mit der Kulturwertmark, das ist ja möglicherweise gar nicht so spannend, aber das ist tatsächlich ein Modell, was ja vom Club auch kommt, nämlich eine neue Idee, wie man möglicherweise Künstler finanzieren könnte.
Ja, genau. Also erstmal soll das nicht die einzige Möglichkeit sein. Florian hat es ja schon angesprochen. Es geht um das nicht-kommerzielle Filesharing, was damit eben weiterhin problemlos, straffrei, legal möglich sein soll. Und es geht nicht darum jetzt irgendwie zu sagen, nur so können Künstler Geld verdienen. Natürlich ist es nach wie vor möglich, Geschäftsmodellen im Netz nachzugehen. Da gibt es schon eine ganze Menge. Ich will da jetzt auch nicht so viele Namen nennen, weil man dann immer Werbung macht für verschiedene Plattformen. Aber es gibt durchaus die Möglichkeit, da Geld zu verdienen. Aber jetzt geht es halt um dieses Filesharing. Und das ist auch ganz, ganz wichtig. Denn letztlich geht es da um die Privatkopie. Die Privatkopie ist etwas, was wir in Deutschland haben und was wir natürlich weiterhin sichern wollen. Und es ist auch klar, wie man das definiert. Also wie gesagt, nicht Kommerzielle Austausch, nicht unbedingt Austausch, aber Filesharing. Das ist es eben. Und das sollte auf keinen Fall irgendwie eingeschränkt werden. Hier schreibt sogar jemand im Pad, Filesharing sei das neue Radio. Also klar, das brauchen wir. Gleichzeitig müssen natürlich auch Urheber irgendwie Geld bekommen.
Wichtiger Punkt glaube ich, weil in der Diskussion werden ja immer diese Extreme dargestellt. Aber es ist schon sozusagen auch ein größerer Konsens, dass ihr sagt, Leute, die Musik machen, sollen schon auch was verdienen können damit.
Ja, weil jetzt sage ich noch eben schon den dritten Punkt, auf den es unbedingt ankommt. Also ich glaube, es gibt drei wichtige Punkte, um die wir nicht herumherum können. Und ich glaube, es gibt auch niemanden, der das anders sieht. Also auch unter den schlimmsten Nomisten, die sagen auch immer, die Urheber sollen Geld bekommen. Und die werden auch jetzt nicht sagen, wir schaffen die Privatkopie ab. Und der dritte Punkt ist sicherlich umstritten. Also es darf keine Überwachungsinfrastruktur geben im Internet. Also dass man in jedes Paket reinschaut, das geht eben einfach nicht in einem freien Land. Das ist glaube ich auch ein breiter Konsens, auch wenn man von Urheber oder Verwertungsrechtler da manchmal was anderes hört. Also das sind die drei Punkte, auf die es ankommt. Jetzt die Frage, wie macht man es? Und jetzt gab es ja diesen Vorschlag der Kulturflatrate, der ist in gewisser Weise problematisch. Erstmal Zwangsabgabe, gut, aber wir haben natürlich auch jetzt schon Zwangsabgaben. Und der nächste Punkt ist halt, das soll dann irgendwie verteilt werden nach irgendwelchen Schlüsseln. Da ist ja die Erfahrung in der Vergangenheit auch nicht so gut mit den Schlüsseln. Und deshalb wäre es eben besser, wenn es eine Möglichkeit gäbe, wo Nutzer selber entscheiden können. Der und der soll eben Geld bekommen. Also ein bisschen wie bei Flatter eben. Nur eben Flatter im großen Stil. Und das ist eben die Idee der Kulturwertmark.
Herr Halt, wie bei Flatter im großen Stil ist keine zulässige Erklärung.
Ja gut, ich hab's ja versucht ein bisschen... Und jetzt Flatter erklären, ja? Okay.
Das ist UKB-Radio.
Ach so.
Nicht alle neben den ganzen Tag im Netz. Also dann...
Erklär mal Flatter. Ne, ne, ne, ne.
Wartet mal. Wir müssen glaub ich einfach nicht Flatter erklären, sondern erklärt einfach mal die Kulturwertmark. Von jemand, der Flatter, für jemand, der Flatter nicht kennt.
Also ich zahle im, also ich zahle im Monat einen Betrag. Ich sagen wir jetzt mal, nur um eine Hausnummer zu nennen, 50 Euro. Dafür bekomme ich eine gewisse Anzahl Kulturwertmarken. Sagen wir jetzt einfach mal zehn Stück. Das sind jetzt keine fixen Zahlen, das sind nur für ein Beispiel. Also jetzt surfe ich durchs Netz und finde eine Band, die ich total geil finde. Oder ein Buch. Oder ein Buch, das ich total geil finde. Oder eine Mischung aus alledem. Oh mein Gott, krasses Musikvideo, das ist ein Kurzfilm, mit einem Buch dabei. Und ich bin jetzt der Meinung, ich möchte diesen Menschen, weil ich es mir runtergeladen habe, Geld dafür geben. Also ich kann jetzt ihm einfach eine Kulturwertmarke geben.
Also das ist dann sozusagen irgendwie auf der Webseite implementiert. Da klickt man was und dann wandert da.
Da kann man sich verschiedene Modelle vorstellen. Das kann man auf der Webseite machen, oder wie ein Kleinschreiben, was auch immer. Das ist auch noch nicht fix. Ich gebe ihm diese Kulturwertmarke. Am Ende des Moors hat er eine gute... Wertmark, nicht Wertmark. Wertmark wie D-Mark. Wertmark, Weinfehler. So, das heißt, ich habe ihm jetzt quasi 5 Euro gegeben. Von meinen 10 Stück, die haben 50 Euro gekostet, sind 5 Euro. Und hier sag ich noch all meinen Kumpels, hier guckt mal wie geil und davon sagen auch noch 5 weitere, finde ich gut. Der kriegt von mir meinen Kulturwertmark. Einer zahlt eine, andere vielleicht drei. Also ganz unterschiedlich. Und am Ende des Moors hat dann der Künstler eine gewisse Summe Kulturwertmark. Und die kriegt er dann gegen wahres getauscht. Also kannste wieder zurücktauschen. Ich hab also mir die Kunst runtergeladen. Ich hab den Künstler entlohnt. Und zwar ganz direkt ohne irgendwelche Zwischenschritte, wie das dann irgendwie 10% Verwaltungsgebühren abfallen oder dergleichen, sondern ganz direkt. Und er bekommt seine Entlohnung. Und zwar dann, weil mir das Werk auch wirklich gefallen hat. Also ich wollte es halt haben.
Also nur um das klarzustellen, es geht nicht darum, dass ich dann Musik nur runterladen darf, wenn ich demjenigen so eine Kulturwertmark gebe, sondern ich darf mir hier alle Musik aus dem Netz runterladen für meinen privaten Gebrauch. Genau. Und zahle aber pflichtgemäß, also muss diesen Anteil zahlen und kann den aber frei verteilen?
Ich kann den frei verteilen, genau.
Okay, aber ich muss ihn zahlen.
Also es gibt die, sofern ich das Konzept richtig verstanden habe, gibt es die Idee, dass jeder Bundesbürger oder jeder, der hier lebt, diese Kulturwertmarken am Anfang des Morals bekommt. Ja, das ist noch nicht richtig ausdiskutiert, ob das über den Internetanschluss geht oder vielleicht auch, man könnte sogar, also es spricht nichts dagegen zu sein, wir machen das komplett freiwillig. Wer das macht, der hat eben das gute Gefühl, ich mache hier Legales und alles ist schön. Also ich würde sogar am Anfang sagen, bevor man jetzt sagt, es ist wieder der Zwangsabgabe, man fängt damit einfach mal an und wer macht es, der macht. Einfach so. Aber es gibt natürlich auch die Vorstellung, dass man sagt, wir binden das an den Internetanschluss, wer einen Internetanschluss hat, der soll sich beteiligen. Der kriegt dann vielleicht irgendwie so einen Zugang und dann ist gut.
Und wenn ich sozusagen zu faul bin zum Klicken oder einfach ein kleiner Verpeiler, dann sammel ich ganz viele Kulturwertmarken auf meinem Konto?
Genau und du verteilst halt nicht, weil du verpeilst die ganze Zeit. Aber am Ende des Mords ist ja klar, wie viele Kulturwertmark verteilt worden sind. Und nehmen wir mal an, deine 10 Stück sind noch da. Die verfallen dann. Die kannst du also nicht sammeln. Du sammelst einen großen Haufen. Und die, die ausgegeben worden sind, aber nicht verteilt wurden, werden dann prozentual an die, die schon welche bekommen haben, nochmal verteilt.
Okay, aber hat man dann nicht auch das klassische Problem, wer eh schon viel hat, bekommt noch mehr?
Ja, das ist in gewisser Weise ein Problem. Also das ist eben das Tim Pertloff-Prinzip. Wo man sagt, was hinterher alle vielleicht erpointen, dass sie bei Tim Pertloff sind. So kann es natürlich auch hier passieren. Dass, also bei Flatter ist ja noch das Problem, dass die Leute ihr Flattergeld dann auch weiter flattern und so. Dass es so eine Art Delegationskette gibt bis zu einer Person. Das muss natürlich so nicht realisiert werden. Aber es kann schon sein, dass natürlich bestimmte Leute sehr viel bekommen, weil sie irgendwie auch sehr netzaffin sind und so. Und immer darauf hinweisen und so und andere weniger. Das ist natürlich schon in gewisser Weise ein Problem. Aber ich denke, das ist immer noch besser als das bisherige Modell, wo ja auch Geld verteilt wird, zum Beispiel über die GEMA. Und die hat aber schon solche Schlüssel, wo auch bestimmte Leute viel kriegen und andere Leute weniger. Und es ist halt auch, es ist zwar nicht intransparent, weil die GEMA ja ihre Sachen erlaufen nicht, aber so richtig schön ist das auch nicht. Und so richtig, naja, also das ist auch kein wirklich gutes Modell. Also dann finde ich es schon besser, wenn letztlich die Nutzer selber entscheiden können. Außerdem ist es datensparsam, auch das ist nochmal ein Punkt.
Aber es muss ja irgendwie festgestellt werden, wie viel, also oder nicht andersrum. Es wird sagen, es wird gar nicht gemessen, wie viel Down runtergeladen wurde.
Genau, das brauchen wir dann nicht mehr zu messen. Wir brauchen keine Überwachung mehr im Internet. Das ist ja gerade das Geniale.
Okay, das heißt aber, wenn jemand total viel getauscht wird, hat er nichts davon, von der Kulturwertmark?
Stückweise nicht, wenn die Leute ihm nichts geben, aber das kann eigentlich nicht sein. Jemand, der wirklich große Aufmerksamkeit erregt und viel bekannt ist und auf jedem Schulhof wird das getauscht, der hat natürlich dann auch wahrscheinlich viele Kulturwertmark.
Aber wahrscheinlich, du sagst, es gibt keine Kopplung.
Ja gut, also wenn es wirklich über den Anschluss geht, also wenn ich die Bezahlung, den Anschluss, dass ich halt diese Kulturwertmark mitkaufen muss, dann ist halt die Sache, ich hab dann das Zeug zu Hause rumfliegen. Also ich hab dann diese Kulturwertmark und ich kann sie ausgeben und ich kann sie liegen lassen. Und wenn ich schon die Chance habe, dann runterzuladen und zu verteilen, weil ich sie sowieso habe, weil ich nicht erst noch extra kaufen gehen muss. Ich muss nicht in den Laden gehen, wo online was klicken, sondern sie sind halt schon da. Das ist glaube ich der große Vorteil. Also ich habe ein Zahlungsmittel, das ich sowieso haben muss.
Ich werde meine eigene Bände und überweis die Kulturwertmark an mich selber.
Ja, gut, aber das kannst du nicht beliebig machen. Also das soll natürlich an der Stelle auch nicht so gehen, dass du einfach Sockenpuppen machst und dir immer das Geld zuspielst. Also das soll ja gerade verhindert werden. Also je nachdem, entweder man macht es über Anmeldung oder man macht es mit einem Internetanschluss, aber nicht so, dass jeder beliebig jetzt sich einfach anmelden kann für seine eigene Band.
Was ich das Spannende finde, ist ja sozusagen, es geht. Das ist ja kein perfektes Konstrukt. Es ist nicht die Wahrheit, TM, sondern ein Diskussionsvorschlag, den ihr gemacht habt, wie man sowas machen könnte. Gibt es denn auch andere in der Richtung, also gibt es überhaupt denn Ideen oder Bewegungen in irgendeiner Art und Weise?
Jaja, also das andere ist ja wie gesagt das Modell der Kulturflatrate, was ja von den Grünen kommt, was im Grunde das System auch fortsetzt, wie es jetzt schon ist. Also zu sagen, dass das was völlig utopisches ist oder dass das gar nicht geht, wie manche Leute sagen, ist ja Quatsch. Ich meine, das ist genau das, was wir jetzt schon haben, mit den Abgaben für Datenträger zum Beispiel, muss man diese Leerabgabe machen, was ja jetzt auch gerade erhöht worden ist für USB-Sticks irgendwie. Wenn die viel mehr Speicherplatz haben, werden die plötzlich teurer. Ja, das gibt es halt schon und das soll eben erweitert werden. Also nicht nur eben möglicherweise auf solche Datenträger, sondern vielleicht auch auf Internet-Anstüsse. Und das ist eben das andere Modell. Das ist halt mit weniger Freiwilligkeit und im bisherigen System, auch wieder mit Verteilungsschlüssel und so, wo man tatsächlich dann Statistiken machen muss und auch überwachen muss, wie viel wo runtergeladen wird, um das eben einigermaßen gerecht verteilen zu können. Ansonsten gibt es auch halt die Idee, also Richtung To-flat-rate aber die Verteilungsschlüssel zu ändern. Also ohne Überwachung. Wir kennen es ja von der GEMA, die verteilt wirklich viele Millionen nach sehr obskuren Verteilungsschlüsseln. Und die sind ein Problem, die Verteilungsschlüssel, wie sie momentan existieren.
Kann man das irgendwie kurz zusammenfassen?
Momentan bekommen die, die eh schon viel verkaufen, auch das meiste von der GEMA ab. Also gerade kleine Künstler, die vielleicht nicht charten im großem Stil, also in den Top 100 Charts, und die auch nicht die großen Verkäufe haben, bekommen ungleich viel, viel weniger als ein Top 10 Künstler.
Sie bekommen nicht nur weniger, weil sie weniger gespielt werden, sondern sie kommen sozusagen im Vergleich weniger.
Sie kommen auch im Vergleich weniger, ja. Und wenn es da ordentlich Verteilschlüssel gäbe, wäre das ganze Thema auch nicht mehr ganz so schlimm, wie es momentan ist. Und man kann sich also vorstellen, dass man die Leerträgerabgabe besser verteilt, dass er unsere Privatkopie sichern soll. Und da muss halt die GEMA grundlegend reformiert werden, für was wahrscheinlich aber nicht so schnell passieren wird.
Was?
Denn die GEMA, darf man nicht vergessen, ist zwar übernimmt eine staatliche Aufgabe wahr, ist aber keine staatliche Behörde oder staatliche Stelle, sondern ist eine Körperschaft des öffentlichen Rechts. Die wurde per Erlass gegründet.
Du sagst gerade so, als möchte ich sofort wissen, was das bedeutet.
Also wir kennen das ja, Behörden gehören irgendwie zu Exekutive dazu. Also zu der ausführenden Gewalt im Staat. Und wir haben in Deutschland die Tradition, dass wir viel auf Selbstregulierung setzen. Und deswegen gibt es Erlasse, die Vereine gründen. Wie zum Beispiel die GEMA oder auch die Kammern sind auch per Erlass gegründet worden. Die IHK und sowas. Wo dann die Menschen, um die es geht, drin Mitglied werden können. Und sich dann quasi selbst verwalten. Und die GEMA ist auch so ein Produkt der Selbstverwaltung der Musiker. Und das ist aber leider schon vor Jahren gehörig in die Hosen gegangen.
Das heißt, im Prinzip wäre es möglicherweise denkbar, dass man da aber was Neues gründet?
Ja sicher. Wie gesagt, es gibt ja jetzt Strukturen. Es gibt diese Zentralstelle für private Überspielrechte. ZPÜ, die übernimmt ja die Verteilung jetzt für die Privatkopie. Das ist eine Zentralstelle, bei der die Verwertungsgesellschaften alle zusammenlaufen sozusagen. Die sitzt auch bei der GEMA. Ja, und wie gesagt, die macht die Verteilung. Und die Frage ist halt, ja, wenn man jetzt so eine Kulturwertmark einführt, will man da unbedingt die ZPÜ verwenden? Oder möchte man da vielleicht besser eine neue Instanz schaffen? Ja, beziehungsweise die ZPÜ ist ja auch nicht das Problem. Da sind die Verwertungsgesellschaften wieder Mitglied. Also GEMA, VG, Word. Und dass die halt schlecht verteilen. Also die ZPÜ verteilt sogar noch recht fair auf die verschiedenen Lärträger. Wir haben ja nicht nur auf Datenträger, sondern auch auf Kopiergeräte diese Abgabe. Die ist ja auch auf Kopiergeräte, die ist auf Computer, die ist auf Laserdrucker, auf Scanner, also auf Festplatten, Bildträger, was auch immer ein Bildträger ist, CD-Rolling, auf alles Mögliche. Und dementsprechend verteilen die auch dann natürlich an die VG, Word, an die GEMA und an andere, je nachdem was für ein Bereich diese Leerträger stammen. Und dann haben die wieder das Verteilproblem. Und das verteilt sich nach diesen bekannten Schlüsseln.
Okay, das heißt, die Idee, dass man möglicherweise eine Alternative für dieses Konzept findet, ist nicht so abwegig. Und wir werden jetzt gleich nach dem Fritz-Info mit Nachrichten, Wetter und Verkehr mit jemandem sprechen, der tatsächlich versucht, eine Alternative zur GEMA auf die Beine zu stellen. Heute Chaosradio im Blue Moon auf Fritz, zu Gast sind vom Chaos Computer Club Maha und Herr Urbach. Hallo und willkommen zurück. Und es geht heute um den Kopierkulturkampf. Kurz lassen sich die ersten anderthalb Stunden der Sendung so zusammenfassen. Der Chaos Computer Club findet es nicht so geil, wenn Leute Gesetze bauen oder Handelsabkommen abschließen, die geheim sind und dann dazu führen, dass das Internet irgendwie überwacht und eingeschränkt wird, nur damit Leute nicht kopieren können. Aber ich finde es eine gute Idee, wenn Künstler, deren Zeug kopiert wird, irgendwie Geld verdienen können. Den ersten, wir haben beides geklärt. Also wir haben über das Handelsabkommen ACTA gesprochen, was genau dieses Ziel hatte und wie der Prozess dagegen organisiert ist und aus welchen Gründen. Und B haben wir über das Ding gesprochen, das sich da Kulturwertmark nennt und was so eine Idee ist, wie man möglicherweise dieses Internetkopie und doch Geld für die Künstler zusammenbringen können. Wir schaffen es jetzt nicht nochmal ganz zusammenzufassen, aber diese Sendung wird es auch als Podcast geben und da könnt ihr das ganz genau nachhören. Jetzt wollten wir, weil wir dann zum Schluss auch auf die GEMA zu sprechen kamen, mal darüber reden, ob es eine Alternative geben muss. Ist das denn generell sowas wie GEMA und ZPÜ? Wie heißt das nochmal?
Zentralstelle für private Überspielrechte.
VG-Wort. Sind die so alt und verknöchert, dass es gar keine andere Wahl mehr gibt, als da was Neues zu bauen? Oder ist es auch für euch denkbar, also pragmatisch denkbar, dass man das von innen umändert?
Also die GEMA-Strukturen sind sehr verknöchert. Also im Vorstand der GEMA sitzt ein Herr Bohlen, der auch gleichzeitig gut daran verdient. Also es fällt Künstlern sehr schwer in der GEMA irgendwas zu wegen. Also auch die Künstler, die da sind, die sagen, das geht so nicht mehr. Also auch die größten Künstler, die sagen, dass die Kleinen zu wenig abbekommen in der Verteilung, die schaffen das nicht zu ändern. Natürlich wurden da großartig Freunde geschaffen für diverse Popkünstler, die man natürlich auch nur schwerlich wieder aufgeben möchte. Und von daher ist es, glaube ich eher, dass es die GEMA, sie zu renovieren, ist nahezu unmöglich. Wir brauchen Alternativen, die nachher aber auch die gleichen Aufgaben wahrnehmen dürfen wie die GEMA. Und das ist dann natürlich dann der nächste... Also erstmal brauchen wir eine Verwerterungswirtschaft, die sich um Rechte kümmert. Also zum Beispiel Airplays, dass da das Geld dann an die Künstler weiter verteilt wird und dergleichen. Aber halt natürlich auch, die dann irgendwann dieses schadliche Privileg bekommen. Also die GEMA hat ja ein Privileg, die GEMA-Vermutung. Sie darf erstmal vermuten, dass alle Musik, die aufgeführt wird, sei es im Radio, sei es im Netz, sei es auf der Bühne, von einem ihrer Künstler stammt. Und ich muss jetzt mal das Gegenteil beweisen.
Deswegen mach ich hier auch gerade die GEMA-Liste fürs Chaosradio, in dem wir nur Creative Commons Musik spielen.
Ja, aber es gibt natürlich nicht nur die GEMA, du hast es ja schon gesagt, es gibt auch noch die anderen Verwertungsgesellschaften, die bei weitem nicht so in der Kritik stehen wie die GEMA. Also es gibt da durchaus auch bessere Modelle. Also von daher würde ich jetzt nicht sagen, Verwertungsgesellschaften sind per se immer schlecht. Oder die französische Partnerorganisation der GEMA hat dort ja sogar Creative Commons mit aufgenommen und auch die Möglichkeit der Parallellizenzierung aufgenommen. Also es gibt durchaus Leute, die die Zeichen der Zeit verstanden haben. Und ich denke, früher oder später wird auch die GEMA begreifen, wo es langgeht. Das dauert bei der halt irgendwie etwas länger. Aber ich wäre jetzt nicht da immer nur pessimistisch. Also ich selbst war ja auf einem Podium in München über Urheberrecht. Und danach hat mich ein Vorstandsmitglied oder Aufsichtsleiter, ich weiß nicht genau, von der ZPÜ angesprochen, ein Prof. Becker. Und der meinte, also er könne sich sowas wie eine Kulturwertmark im Rahmen der ZPÜ durchaus auch vorstellen. Gut, das mag jetzt eine Minderheitenmeinung sein bei denen, aber man sieht, die sind jetzt nicht alle nur auf Ablehnung. Also das kann da vielleicht auch funktionieren, aber wahrscheinlich braucht es noch eine Zeit, da Überzeugungsarbeit zu leisten.
Und möglicherweise geht diese Überzeugungsarbeit ein bisschen schneller, wenn doch mal jemand eine Alternative auf die Beine stellt, zum Beispiel für die GEMA. Und Mike Michalke ist einer von einem Team von Leuten, die genau das versuchen und jetzt am Telefon Hallo und guten Abend, Mike. Kannst du mal kurz erklären, was du da treibst und warum das so lange dauert?
Oh, das sind ja gleich zwei Dinge auf einmal. Also erstmal versuchen wir, tatsächlich eine alternative Verwertungsgesellschaft für Musik aufzubauen. Und die meisten, die bei uns daran arbeiten, kommen so aus dem Creative Commons Sektor. Also was uns als erstes am meisten gestört hat an der GEMA, war, dass man dort als Musiker keine Möglichkeit hat, einzelne Stücke rauszunehmen und unter einer Creative Commons Lizenz ins Netz zu stellen.
Das heißt also, wenn ich Künstler bin, der einmal bei der GEMA sich registriert hat, dann ist alles, was ich abdenke, bis ich aus der GEMA wieder austrete und auch darüber hinaus, dann sozusagen der GEMA für die Verwertung angeschrieben.
Genau, die GEMA hat quasi so ein Prozedere, dass man, wenn man dort Mitglied wird, die es ja als Verein strukturiert, dass man dann sein gesamtes Repertoire der GEMA zur Verwertung gibt und dann eben nicht einzelne Stücke wieder rausnehmen kann, um die dann getrennt davon zu lizensieren. Und das ist ja eigentlich genau quasi der Kontrapunkt, den die Creative Commons Lizenzen setzen, die halt eher so gestrickt sind, dass man für jedes einzelne Stück oder jedes einzelne Werk, um das allgemeiner zu sagen, einzeln entscheiden kann, unter welchen Bedingungen man das lizenzieren will. Und das ist eben genau das, was wir mit unserem Projekt, das nennt sich Cultural Commons Collecting Society, eben realisieren wollen.
Und habt ihr bis auf den kompliziert zu merkenden Namen noch andere Probleme? Weil ich kann mich erinnern, dass es schon sehr lange her ist, dass wir mal hier ein Interview bei Fritz hatten, als das Projekt in Angriff genommen wurde.
Ja, wir haben glaube ich vor anderthalb Jahren oder so was mal darüber gesprochen. Vor knapp zwei Jahren auf jeden Fall haben wir das Ganze veröffentlicht, einfach nur so als Idee. Und seitdem diskutieren wir quasi mit allen, die halt seitdem an uns herangetreten sind und gesagt haben, das ist eine coole Idee, halt darüber, wie man das tatsächlich realisieren kann. Es gibt halt wirklich unglaublich viele Problemfelder, mit denen man sich da beschäftigen muss. Das fängt halt an, zum Beispiel bei den gesetzlichen Grundlagen, die es für Verwertungsgesellschaften gibt. Also man braucht jetzt nicht unbedingt, wie ich gerade gehört habe, einen staatlichen Erlass oder so, um eine Verwertungsgesellschaft zu gründen, sondern es gibt das Urheberrechtswahrnehmungsgesetz, in dem zum Beispiel geregelt ist, was eine Verwertungsgesellschaft ist, wen die als Mitglied aufnimmt und wem die eine Lizenz geben muss und so weiter. Und da ist auch drin geregelt, dass das Patent- und Markenamt in München die Staatsaufsicht darüber hat. Von denen haben wir heute auch Post gekriegt. Die wissen ja auch, dass es uns gibt und die möchten jetzt gerne mehr Informationen. Und das finde ich halt zum Beispiel super, dass wir halt vom Patentamt jetzt einen Brief kriegen, in dem drin steht, ja, Sie möchten gerne eine Verwaltungsgesellschaft gründen. Bitte geben Sie uns mehr Informationen. Das funktioniert offensichtlich relativ gut mit dieser Staatsaufsicht. Und das sind halt eben so Probleme, mit denen wir uns halt beschäftigen, okay, was sind jetzt genau die Schritte? Man muss zum Beispiel, um so eine Lizenz zu bekommen, ein entsprechendes Repertoire vorweisen können. Man muss dann sagen können, wie die Verwaltungsstruktur aufgebaut sein soll. Man muss zum Beispiel auch offenlegen, wie man die Gelder verteilen will. Also in dem Gesetz ist auch geregelt, dass es tatsächlich einen definierten Schlüssel geben muss, nachdem die Gelder verteilt werden und so weiter. Und das muss jetzt halt alles nach und nach aufgebaut werden. Dafür braucht man einen wirtschaftlichen Sachverstand, juristischen Sachverstand. Und wir sammeln halt jetzt seit zwei Jahren immer mehr Leute ein, die sich genau dafür interessieren.
Und geht das dann nur für Creative Commons Musik? Oder plant ihr auch so dieses Filesharing-Problem und überhaupt das Ganze da irgendwie mit in deine Not zu bringen?
Das Filesharing-Problem, um das quasi direkt zu lösen, müsste man ja tatsächlich auf Urheberrechtsebene ansetzen oder sowas. Wir versuchen das quasi indirekt irgendwie abzufedern, dadurch, dass es halt, wenn so eine Verwertungsgesellschaft für CC-Musik existiert, es tatsächlich auch real möglich ist, darauf ein Kulturwirtschaftssystem aufzubauen, also dass dann auch große Lizenznehmer, die halt wirklich dann auch richtig viel Geld da reinspielen können, eine Stelle haben, an die sie sich wenden können mit wir haben hier eine Liste von 300 Titeln, wir brauchen dafür eine Lizenz. Das ist halt im Augenblick eigentlich total unpraktikabel für wirklich größere Lizenznehmer, wie zum meinetwegen Clubs oder große Unternehmen, die einfach viele Titel für eine Werbekampagne oder sowas benutzen wollen. Die müssen im Augenblick halt für jeden einzelnen Track, den die verwenden wollen, erst mal rausfinden, wer sind die Urheber davon und dann mit denen einzelne Verträge aushandeln und so weiter und das ist halt unglaublich langartig. Deswegen ist das für die einfach nicht besonders attraktiv. Die gehen dann halt lieber gleich zur GEMA, da haben die halt diese eine Stelle und bezahlen da einmal dann halt die ausgerechnete Lizenzgebühr und dann sind die halt zufrieden.
Das heißt, eure Verwaltungswirtschaft richtet sich gezielt nur an die großen Player?
Nicht gezielt nur, sondern sie richtet sich an alle, die irgendwie kommerziell mit diesen Werken tätig werden wollen. Und zugleich wollen wir aber auch so neuere Entwicklungen im Netz, so Social Media Entwicklungen aufnehmen und halt auch freiwillige Zahlungen, also quasi diese Flettersysteme halt auch ermöglichen. Also dass es auch möglich ist, obwohl man keine Gebühren zahlen muss, den Leuten, die das gerne machen wollen, eine Möglichkeit zu geben, dass unkompliziert über eine neutrale Stelle, die nicht selbst noch Geld verdienen will, Verwertungsgesellschaften sind ja von Gesetz her daran gebunden, dass sie nicht selbst in eigenem wirtschaftlichen Interesse arbeiten, sondern wirklich nur treuhänderisch die Gelder weiterverwalten, dass über so einen Service international und zwar auch gleich europaweit zum Beispiel auch freiwillige Zahlungen gemacht werden kann.
Wie wollt ihr denn feststellen, wer wieviel kriegt? Wollt ihr dann irgendwie Downloads messen oder müssen dann die Leute dann auch wieder Listen ausfüllen wie bei der GEMA oder wie soll das laufen?
Die Leute, die tatsächlich kommerziell das verwenden wollen, die müssen dann logischerweise weiter Listen führen. Da sehen wir auch kein großes Datenschutzproblem. Ob jetzt dann in welchem Club welcher Titel gespielt wurde, das ist jetzt irgendwie nicht so das große Ding. Und bei den freiwilligen Zahlungen müssen wir gar nicht wissen, wer welche Musik wann gehört hat. Es geht halt nur darum, dass wir wissen, wer von seinem Etat welchem Künstler was geben will.
Okay, das wird dann einfach direkt auch angesagt mit der Zahlung. Habt ihr hier Maha und Herr Obach von diesem Projekt schon gehört?
Ja.
Geht das irgendwie zusammen oder ist das nochmal eine eigene Baustelle?
Ich hab davon schon mal gehört und ich halte das für sinnvoll. Einfach um weniger das Problem Filesharing in den Griff zu kriegen, aber einfach um den Gedanken der freien Lizenzen weiter voranzutreiben, was einfach unglaublich wichtig ist. Ich möchte, wenn ich zum Beispiel ein Musikstück veröffentliche, also diese Doppel-Lizenzierung eigentlich. Ich will es halt einmal für share-like, also einfach normal veröffentlichen, und einmal mit NC. Und es muss halt klar sein, wer macht hier gerade was und dass da nicht Leute an den Kragen gepisst bekommen, weil plötzlich irgendwas doch kommerziell sein soll, obwohl sie zu Hause eine Party gefeiert haben. Aber ich finde, das ist glaube ich ein wichtiger Aspekt, die Doppel-Lizenzierung. Ich kann ein Werk so auflizenzieren, wie ich möchte, in den verschiedensten Lizenzen. Da eben nicht, wenn du GEMA-Mitglied bist. Dann eben nicht mehr. Und das ist halt wirklich die Sache dahinter. Und ich halte das für total wichtig, gerade um den CC-Gedanken zu stärken und freie Kultur zu fördern.
So, Mike, wie gesagt, das geht ja schon irgendwie eineinhalb Jahre, zwei Jahre. Gibt es schon so einen Glaskugeltermin, wann es möglicherweise unter Umständen eventuell mal losgehen könnte?
Ja, wir haben ja jetzt die letzten Wochen auch ordentlich Presse gekriegt, nachdem wir das auf der Second nochmal gebracht haben und in diversen anderen Veranstaltungen, Future Music Camp und so weiter. Der Schlüsselpunkt ist jetzt im Augenblick im Wesentlichen das Repertoire, dass wir das zusammenkriegen. Das sieht aber gerade sehr gut aus. Man kann sie auf unserer Homepage auf so ein Newsletter eintragen und dann geht da auf jeden Fall auch die Meldung raus, wenn es wirklich ernst wird, sich zu melden mit Repertoire. So genau kann man das nicht sagen. Das Repertoire muss halt im Verhältnis zu den Verwaltungskosten insgesamt stehen. Das heißt, man kann theoretisch mit ein paar Künstlern das machen, wenn man halt quasi null Verwaltungskosten hat, weil dann irgendwie auch rein wirtschaftlich das Geld, was reinkommt, auch an die Künstler ausgezahlt werden kann.
Verstehe, verstehe. Also ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, großartiger Plan, aber ich beneide euch nicht, das scheint mir doch sehr komplex zu sein.
Das ist es auch, ja. Um noch eine Zeitmarke zu nennen, wir haben halt wirklich vor, zum Ende des Jahres tatsächlich die Lizenz beim Patentamt zu beantragen.
Okay, dann lass uns wissen, wann es soweit ist. Und vielen Dank erstmal für diesen Einblick. Alles klar. Das war Mike, Michalke. Und dazu wird es auch einen Link geben in den Sendungsnotizen.
Ich möchte noch ganz kurz zu GEMA sagen. Hätte mich vorhin gesagt, dass es kein Verein ist, es ist eine Stiftung. Und es ist eine per Erlass gegründete Stiftung. Es ist aber das gleiche Prinzip, als wenn es eine Behörde gibt, die hat einen Erlass, dass der GEMA ergründet werden soll. Das macht das im Ministerium. Und der Herr Bundespräsident muss zustimmen. Und dann gibt es diese Behörden. Oder diese Behörden ähnlichen Strukturen. Also es ist eine rechtsfähige öffentliche Stiftung des behördlichen Rechts.
Jetzt haben wir in den letzten fast zwei Stunden besprochen die beiden großen Dinge. Nämlich A, es gibt halt immer Gesetzgebung, die sehr hart wirkt und gegen die ihr protestieren wollt. Und andererseits gibt es so ein paar Ideen, wie man diese neue Situation, die im Internet jetzt gerade einfach mal herrscht, mit dem Tauschen von Dateien und Kunstwerken, auffängt und möglicherweise auch finanzierbar macht. Aus der Perspektive zu sagen von euch betrachtet, sieht das im Prinzip so aus gerade. Protest, Protest, Protest. Und nochmal Ideen entwickeln. Wie sieht denn das jetzt in näherer Zukunft aus? Also wenn ich jetzt mal zynisch pragmatisch denke, denke ich so, die Abmahnanmelde werden auch in den nächsten 5 Jahren noch ihr Geld verdienen. Was sind denn jetzt so?
Da müsste man glaube ich, da kann man glaube ich gegen vorgehen. Also das Massenabmahnend, dass das keine Perspektive hat, da sind sicher praktisch alle einig. Also da gibt es auch wieder ein ganz breites Bündnis über alle Parteien hinweg. Also das ist sicherlich auch, da kriegt man sogar die CDU und CSU ins Boot. Naja, die haben halt viele Juristen, die haben auch viele Leute, also viele Richter. So Richter und Professoren gelten ja immer sehr konservativ in Deutschland. Die möchten aber nicht dauernd mit diesem Abmahnzeug zu tun haben. Und von daher denke ich, werden wir das noch in den nächsten fünf Jahren erleben, dass es Maßnahmen gibt gegen Massenabmahn. Also ich denke, das wird wirklich verschwinden. Wir müssen dann aufpassen, dass nicht an die Stelle der Massenabmahnung dann irgendwie so ein Three-Strikes-Modell ist. Genau, das ist ja auch bestätigt worden. Das wäre natürlich schlimmer. Das wäre tatsächlich den Teufel mit dem Pelzebump verjagen. Aber ich fand es halt schon schön, dass sich die Justizministerin ganz klar gegen Massenabmahnung positioniert hat. Jetzt warten wir auf die Initiative aus dem Justizministerium, um das halt irgendwie gesetzlich in den Griff zu kriegen. Ansonsten war auch schön, dass Diskussionen über Tooth Strikes, also das Warnsystem der deutschen Musikwirtschaft und auch Three Strikes, die bisher immer kaputt gegangen sind und abgespittert worden sind. Also ich hoffe, dass wir auch da unsere Politik da, was das betrifft, standhaft bleibt und einfach erkennt, dass Internet mehr ist als nur ein bisschen rumklicken, sondern wirklich für Menschen Lebensraum.
Also wenn man euch hier so im Studio sieht, würde ich ja manchmal denken, das ist nicht der Fall.
Aber nur weil wir klicken können. Naja, wir müssen auch nochmal ganz klar da sagen, dieses Abmahnen, das bringt den Urhebern nichts. Mir ist ja vorgeworfen worden, ich sei gegen, wenn ich gegen Abmahn sei, sage ich auch gegen die Steuerfahndung. Das ist natürlich blödsinnig, weil die Steuerfahndung natürlich tatsächlich dafür sorgt, dass Steuern einkommen. Das Abmahn bringt aber nur den Abmahnanwälten etwas und nicht den den Urhebern.
Nein, nicht ganz. Auf Spiegel gibt es gerade ein schönes Interview zwischen Christoph Lau und Jan Dilä und der sagt da so, ja er hätte in seiner letzten Abrechnung entdeckt, da wäre ihm tatsächlich auch Geld zugutekommen.
Dann hat es aber in seinem Vertrag so drinne stehen, dass aus den Abmahnungen dann auch Gelder an ihn fließen. Aber das Gro bleibt beim Abmahnanwalt, dann geht ein Teil an das Label oder den Verwerter halt, der die Abmahnung hervorgerufen hat und der kann entscheiden, was er damit macht. Der kann es auch für sich behalten. Weil er mahnt ja die unrechtmäßige Verwertung ab. Und die Verwertungsrechte hat der Künstler im Regelfall mit seinem Vertrag an die jeweilige Verwertung abgetreten.
Wir kommen jetzt quasi im Kreis zum Anfang der Sendung zurück. Da ging es ja um ACTA, dieses Handelsabkommen, wo genau dieses Two-Strikes oder Three-Strikes irgendwie auch mal drin stand. Also von wegen, wenn du böse bist, dann mahne ich deinen Ted Provider ab und schalte dir irgendwann das Netz aus. Da soll jetzt am 9. Juni, also nächsten Samstag, ein Protestaktions- irgendwas-Ding stattfinden. Beginnt 12 Uhr an der Oberbaumbrücke, habe ich schon gelernt. Was passiert da noch?
Naja, wie gesagt, es gibt da verschiedene Aktionen. Erstmal ist dieser Aktionstag weltweit, also international. Man kann, also man muss nicht zur Oberbaumbrücke. Da wird es eh dann wahrscheinlich zu voll. Offenbar, zumindest. Und es gibt natürlich auch noch andere Aktionen. Also es wird nicht einfach nur eine Demo geben. Es wird andere Leute geben, die vielleicht an der Oberbaumbrücke mit dem Floß starten und so. Also es gibt, da soll ja eine ganz bunte, ganz bunter Aktionstag sein. Mit ganz unterschiedlichen Aktivitäten.
Und wo findet das in Deutschland sonst noch statt?
In allen großen Städten. In Frankfurt bin ich in Kontakt mit den Leuten, die das vorbereiten. Also das ist, wie ich sagte ja schon, am einfachsten ist wirklich mit einer freien Suchmaschine einfach mal zu gucken und dann findet man sofort für seine Stadt die Aktion. Wenn es noch keine gibt und man in einer etwas größeren Stadt wohnt, dann sollte man sich selber sofort wachen, aktivieren. Ansonsten gibt es irgendwie da so ein Wiki von Stop ACTA Protest Info, das auch irgendwie Informationen bereithält. Das ist ein offenes Wiki, kann sich jeder eintragen, nur wiki.stopacta-protest.info Da finden sich auch alle Infos zu den jeweiligen Demos und zwar weltweit. Wir haben für Deutschland, ich klicke jetzt mal auf Deutschland drauf, gucke mal.
Live-Internet im Radio?
Ja, unglaublich. Augsburg, Ahlen, Landkreis Aurich, Berlin, Braunschweig, Bremen, Bremerhaven, Chemnitz, Dresden, Essen, Frankfurt am Main, Freiburg, Kreiswald.
Die Nachfolgesendung beginnt um 12 Uhr. Gibt es ansonsten Club-Technisch, also Chaos Computer Club, Chaos Radio, gibt es da noch irgendwie so Termine jetzt hier in Berlin, die man an den Mann bringen könnte, jeden Donnerstag?
Ja, jeden Donnerstag, genau. Im Chaos Computer Club ab 17 Uhr ist da jeder willkommen und jede willkommen bis Mitternacht. Also offenes Chaos, der sogenannte Club Discordia, ihr findet da immer statt. Also da kann man natürlich auch hinkommen und sich aktivieren. Und ansonsten für die Hackerinnen und Hacker da draußen, die GPN ist nächste Woche ab Donnerstag in Karlsruhe. Die Gulasch Programmier-Nacht mit Vorträgen, Hacken, Zusammensetzen. Oder in Brandenburg, wir machen hier Radio für Brandenburg. Die hedonistische internationale hat ihr Camp in der Nähe von Wittstock, also an der Dosse.
Die hedonistische internationale, falls ihr gerade nicht wisst, was das ist, empfinde ich euch da.
CAE 185.
Genau, und dann mal nachzugucken, was sie so getrieben haben, das sind sehr lustige Leute. Das Chaosradio war es damit. Vielen Dank an Herr Obach und Herrn Maha, die hier im Studio waren und uns ACTA und Kulturwertmark und andere urheberrechtliche Dinge erklärt haben. Ich bedanke mich bei euch fürs Zuhören und auch Mitmachen. Das Ganze gibt es als Podcast demnächst auf friz.de und dann ein bisschen später auch auf chaosradio.de. Hier kommt jetzt Henrik Schröder mit einem Punk-Rock-Nightflight und wird euch Musik in die Ohren hauen, die sie möglicherweise zum Blut bringen. Ich bin damit raus, mein Name ist Markus Richter und ich kann nur noch eins sagen, macht immer schon eure Backups und lasst euch nicht überwachen.